this week i'm working on the top layer
of logic in the recipe box
[Music]
i started with routine in order to do it
i installed react router and history
later i imported
router route index route and hash
history
appropriately to the files next i named
the path and the components and that
will be
loaded in a given path
the index route in my case is home page
so component called home
the next step this week was learning
more about local storage i used it a few
times for example in pomodoro clock but
i had to come back to
json stringify or jason pars because i
didn't remember that
[Music]
[Music]
the next step is uh the most tricky for
me because it's the top level logic so
the logic on the level of pages and
connecting everything with local storage
i want to start it with the free
functions so
saving the recipe to data storage
loading a given recipe from data storage
and
retrieving all recipes getting all the
recipes from data storage let's get back
to work
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this week was difficult the project is
quite hard because
it's got a lot of components and i added
also extra functionality but i don't
manage however there are the moments
where you are fed up that something
doesn't go as you want and you have to
consult it many times online check the
stuff and
stack overflow
back free code
asking questions to the stack overflow
that really solve your problems
knowing a lot
learning fast
but life
isn't so easy
and said that it's hard you develop so
if it's too easy
you don't develop that's why i think
that it's all worth doing but
but sometimes it's
annoying that
you don't know that something doesn't
work again and you even don't get what's
written in stack overflow
[Music]
life
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
this week in malaga snow and
for malaga area this is a kind of money
when it snows in spain in andalusia so
in the south of spain it's really a
problem because there's no central
heating in the houses and floods and
generally you have just some air
conditioning or extra radiators that you
have to buy
fortunately i have air conditioning nice
blanket
and
we bought some a theater however snow in
malaga is something rare it wasn't
snowing here for decades climate changes
are real and
global warming doesn't mean that it
should be really hotter technology
without clear thinking and global
sustainable solutions wouldn't save the
world
[Music]
it's the end of the week this is how it
looks now this is the home page and
with react i'm right now going to
create a recipe view
so on create page i can add
[Music]
tags
[Music]
i can add a photo and create right now
ingredients
[Music]
instructions
and i can save the recipe
when the recipe is saved
it's already in the local storage
with the name
tags
image
[Music]
instructions and ingredients
in code it looks like that
[Music]
so
i
created additional file
logic.js
in which i get at these
free functions save recipe
low recipe and recipe list
which i use later in addition
importing the function that i need
from logic ds
[Music]
and
i created
the constructor
uh
and in the state i got an object with
the key of name tags image ingredients
and instructions i added the methods on
title change
on text change
on image change and ingredients and an
instruction change where where i catch
the changes and save them
to local storage
it says that i introduced routine and
thanks to this routine i can come from
one page the other
[Music]
so
for example
this
add button here goes to
adding the recipe in home js
i have
used link
that's the redirecting to edition
and
in main.js
i added paths
that is index route addition and details
when i go to edition i go to edition.js
and i'm here so
i can
see the addition mode
which means that i'm here
and this is the example how i connected
everything with routine
next week i will continue with the rest
of the app because still it needs much
much more wag keep on doing remember
that we have one planet and one life
see you next week
you